if a writer does break into television
what can they expect and what are they
going to need to know to survive as a
television writer I mean is there an
unspoken protocol that did you saying
that the 50 rolls of writing aren't
ready they're not written down um Walter
Bennett told us a nice story when he was
a rookie writer in a room he pitched a
joke and all painting and then 20
minutes later one of the more seasoned
writers pitched the same joke and
everybody cracked up and he said hey I
just pitched that joke 20 minutes ago
the showrunner turn to him said come on
don't be like that it's when you're the
new guy any place when you're a rookie
yeah so it's about politics Oh major
league politics and the bigger the show
the more the staff the more politics is
why my student Sarah a couple of the
faculty you heard about her getting this
break on this A&E show oh no she should
be in a big room having to fight for
historian and my attitude about that is
she's learning her craft in a in a
relatively calm environment she's going
to have enough of that later let her
learn you know she got lucky so that yes
most I know this is true on our shows
that most of the time on a show like The
Good Wife the rookie writers what we
call baby writers don't get a script the
first year they don't get or if they do
it doesn't necessarily go past the table
when we interviewed David Brickman he
said he spent a year in SNL and said
getting something on the air says half
the cast comes in with characters they
already have that they write stuff for
and then the guest comes in with certain
bits that they do so the number of new
bits that are totally written from
scratch very small number and
everybody's competing for those spots
this very time what about non-creative
etiquette what do you mean how should
one conduct themselves suppose they do
get this group this job this television
job oh I am very strong feelings about
okay um one the mythology that that you
go in and and show everybody how smart
you are it's really stupid well that
ends up showing everybody how arrogant
you are I think what people look for is
is is for you to prove yourself over
time and to listen and to be there to
learn most people who go have another
friend Gloria colored Calderon who
actually broke in through her plays and
was on how about your mother for the
first five seasons and a lot of other
shows right now she's doing Mark
Cherry's new show the guy that created
desperate housewives and she's also
teaching for us again she likes to come
in she was a LM you graduate and she
likes to come back and teach um she said
that her first year in a television show
she listened a lot and she opened her
mouth only when she had something that
she was really certain about and she
really looked to the older riders the
more experienced writers to help her so
politically attaching yourself to people
who know more than you do is the only
smart politically but it's also you're
gonna learn more you don't learn
anything from the other baby writers
they're in the same situation you are
just like getting along in prison you
the new without the other part of it
that we won't mention because this is
going to be on YouTube and there are
restrictions but yeah I mean I think the
main the main thing I've learned is the
etiquette should be and you know be nice
to people because that old rule about
who you see on the way up is if you're
gonna meet on the way down so I don't
think anybody ever get there's a couple
of people who are absolutely
works but for the most part people are
people like they are in any other
business they're going to be on the show
runners going to be under a lot of
stress because they do more than just
sit in that room but most of the shell
runners I've known are really great
people and and sweet you know I'm good
people and artists and artists are you
know they're up and down but I think you
learn more by listening never been my
gift but no I'm kidding but I think
that's not true cuz you listen to
yourself as you speak that's true we you
know we had stories about showrunners
that in the book the ranged from people
who walked on water to people who said
be submerged way under it and all the
points in between there's a bad apples
every punch yeah Bell really colors the
flavor of the room Peter Casey talked
about a room he was in where he came to
the room late one day brought his own
corn flakes with him and went to pour
milk in there and the showrunner came
and said that's just for coffee he says
they were that cheap oh and said he
learned you know we could take the cast
add the writing room out for dinner feta
stay late you have to treat them much
nicely and you got much more out of them
yeah that too Charles brothers who you
mentioned taxi they used to take
everybody Jason's which you know the
Gradle now closed restaurant they used
to take them you know 4 premieres of the
show and cast parties and they treat
Phil Rosenthal used to have activities
that he would do with the writers room
you know everybody on the show would go
to Disneyland on a weekend and they
would pay for everything probably the
network paid for it but um nope I think
I'm only two people left Raymond in the
all the years it was on and one came
back so two people left and they both
went to sex in the city and one came
back and sex that they described are
like family yeah you know there are
other rooms where people were saying I
just hated walking in there
yes yeah yeah it's interesting the
pressure that um one of the writers from
Raymond luchshe nighter told us a great
story that he was in a room and lose
also stand up and the writer next to him
said he whispered a joke to him and said
would you pitch it for me because he
didn't think he was a good enough joke
teller and Lou was a stand-up and he
wanted to make sure he got his joke and
he wanted the best presentation of it I
mean it shows you what some of the
pressures like they're sometimes know
your strength I think and work on your
weaknesses is what I I've heard you know
that's what a lot of I didn't like the
room I have to be honest I I've only
been in a few because what I was doing
it full time it was still there was a
lot of freelancing and I don't think
there's enough freelancing now I think
shows get stale very quickly because the
same eight people are writing it you
know that works on HBO and Showtime
because they don't do more than 12 they
do the British model of 12 to 13 shows a
year but when you're doing 24 good wives
they can all be good you know and I
don't know it's it's sometimes I think
they get stale and there's a big
difference between the sopranos and
revenge for example which seems to me a
little longer only seen two episodes but
it seems a little so be you know so I
think you know I think we might all be
better off if there were more
freelancing but I didn't like the room I
I was never comfortable in it My partner
was great in it again cuz she was an
actress and she was very good doing that
stuff I couldn't wait to get out of
there and write something which by the
way nobody in the writers room ever
really wants to do they would much
rather sit there and talk about sports
and who they are dating and and that is
about half of what goes on in the
writers room I would say more than half
probably and a lot of eating so it
sounds like you
have to be really good so said yes yes
or be with a partner who's really good
um if I were doing it now at my advanced
age I would probably enjoy it more I
just didn't I didn't like the judgment
constant judgment you got to be willing
to be and I never had those experiences
where it was like Raymond where people
were really respected or you know like
cheers or Frasier were people you know
one of the things that Lou Schneider
told us in show me the funny I just
thought I'd mention the name of the book
he's anybody wants to buy it is that a
lot of what's wrong with television is
that people get through on false credits
so that you hire somebody who has
credits that they really didn't earn
they're not their credits which i think
is fascinating and it explains a lot of
what I've seen over the 25 years that
I've been around it you know it's like
that is really scary that they could get
hired on something and then of course
they can't deliver you know there's a
thing in movies called a discretionary
fund that what an actor has had a number
of hits like Emilio Estevez this is a
great story of Emilio Estevez when when
the mighty duck movies were doing so
well the studio gave him a discretionary
fund which is really just saying here
develop some properties we may or may
not make them and I don't even know if
they're doing that with anybody but the
really big stars now and he developed he
developed the script which sold on the
pitch which was a fish comes up on land
this is all these two guys said a fish
comes up on land and has to end and
becomes half human and has to interact
with human beings and figure out how to
get back in the water and they bought it
and the course they never made it so
there's a lot of I know this is really
far from the writers room I you might
have noticed I have a TV but that's okay
you know we've all got our crosses to
bear yours today is my
yeah so yeah I mean I I again it's like
a lot of what gets by in Hollywood is
based on an idea and you could be great
at pitching by the way but if you can't
write if you can't write sooner or later
someone's gonna figure that out you know
so you might think about bringing a
producer along who can help you not only
pitch it but develop it into a good
script because Peters got a very close
friend who is a great producer and a
manager who I think has made scripts
better by being in that partnership of
that so I don't I'm wandering a bit i'm
sorry Karen I wander I think some people
you know even though they might be very
creative in in large groups I think
sometimes they can have problems and I
think that makes them seen one way but
they're really not it's just that social
anxiety or whatever it is what we
interviewed Michael allies we rooms were
just starting to be in vogue now in
sitcoms he he and his partner created
head of the class his pride back with
70s and he said that's not writing and
what comes out of there doesn't sound
like one person's voice mm-hmm so he
always thought with it yeah I don't
think I would do all the room are you
doing fine here well yeah but I'm good
in small groups I'm not good in way it's
a room yeah and Alan Ball you know feel
like Alan Ball Aaron Sorkin they have
very small rooms and they'll tell you
right up for Aaron Sorkin tells his
staff I'm gonna listen to all your ideas
were a football but I'm gonna write the
scripts hmm how he gets that voice yeah
you know
you